Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'm stranded in the
wilderness of Alaska for the last 3 days
I've been solo camping in Alaska's
rainforest I've used float planes canoes
and my own two feet in order to explore
remote Hot Springs but my plane was
supposed to pick me up this morning and
it didn't show up I'm not sure how I'm
going to get home but one thing's for
sure this is going to be an interesting
[Music]
video
okay hi thank you
[Music]
guys
thank
you thank
[Applause]
you well I'm all by myself
now I've got lots of different ammo I've
got slugs for Bears I've got birdshot
it's a nice thing about shotguns they're
versatile there we go it's going to
leave my gun case in the bushes I'll get
it on my way back well guys welcome to
the temperate rain forest of of
Southeast Alaska it rains over 270 days
out of the Year here and we're about 45
miles north Northeast of katchin
Alaska all right we better get Trucking
got a long way to
go look at this place it's a cold Jungle
everything is covered in
Moss
look at the size of this log this is
crazy
look at
this that's pretty
cool well this is the lake I was trying
to find unfortunately I'm on the wrong
end of the lake and it's a big lake sure
is
pretty hold on there's a little
something over
there
Che it out it's an Old
Trolley all the woods rotted away but
you can still see the metal
frame oh that is slick you see the
trolley pretty good here I think
normally the water level is a little bit
lower and you can walk out to that thing
but hey I got a great view of the
Lake look at
this looks a little beat
up National Forest Service left these
canoes here for anybody to use as long
as you take care of them put them back
where you found them everyone can enjoy
them it's a real great
thing
wooho you know what rain or no rain this
is still pretty cool look at
this there's a couple Ducks right over
there I think I might go get
them oh there they go well they didn't
let me get close to them but they're
here and that's a good sign if I get up
early tomorrow morning I think I might
have a good chance at
them
there we go we got ourselves a nice
little shelter going to need it cuz I've
already wet my
pants well this is a pretty slick Little
Shelter it was built in 1937 so it's
almost 90 years old just made with logs
and cedar shingles got a nice little
shelf up here you can sleep on or use
for storage look at the big old solid
benches
here got even a little bit of wood here
I might be able to chop up this is a
pretty cool spot but I got to get my
tent set up I am really wet and
cold
I'll check this
out it's a volcanic hot spring look at
all the steam coming off this
water oh that's
warm see if we can jam this hole
up there we go it's filling up with hot
water pretty
quick SK scaling hot right
there this right here must be the
source woo yeah that's boiling this over
here is just warm you can see all the
steam coming off the hillside there's
probably other hot springs popping out
higher up there now there's a hose over
there bringing hot water down the hill
we got to figure out why it's not
working
there we
go that's hot all right so we got cold
water there boiling hot water there and
warm water flowing in here and you can
kind of use the three to adjust your
temperature oh man I want to jump in
this right now but it's getting dark and
I'm getting hungry and I need to give
this some time to clean out the pool and
get it nice and
warm
woo that is so awesome I think the only
thing that could be more exciting than
that is a hot meal oh I am so
hungry these BR wors are pre-cooked so
you just want to warm them up really put
a little bit of water the bottom of the
frying pan bring it to a boil by the
time the water evaporates the BR worst
is piping hot through and
through oh that's delicious it's not
fancy but it's warm and it's quick two
things I really appreciate right
now there we
[Music]
go
I'll tell you what guys I am exhausted I
had to get up at 5:30 in the morning to
catch my flight spent all day on a plane
and then I had to hurry as fast I could
to get here before Sunset didn't even
have time to eat
lunch
got my hot water bottle here check for
leaks all right looks good let's put
that in there well I got some bread
flour with me and tomorrow morning I'm
going to eat hot fresh bread so I'm
going to go ahead and mix up a little
water with it give it a little mix let
it sit overnight and it'll be fermented
and all ready to go tomorrow
morning making fresh bread is one of my
favorite things to eat on a camp out and
I get people asking me all the time how
you do it I did an entire video on how
to make campfire bread it's really
easy just going to hang it up on this
clothes line so mice can't get at it
well I think I am ready to get out of
these wet
clothes all
right well the sun set about an hour ago
and it's only 7:15 it is getting dark so
early
nowadays I'm just going to kind of hop
into bed and eat some snacks and listen
to an Audi book I've got a pumpkin pie
infused goua cheese which is going to be
kind of wild got some chocolate covered
hazelnuts a wicked salami fig cake and
some pilot bread so yes I'm having an
awesome
time Sun's just barely up and it's not
raining so I think I should go do some
duck hunting oh yeah these didn't dry
out at all last night this is not going
to be
fun
so that flock of ducks is right back
where they were yesterday I'm going to
try to stalk
them oh there was about 15 ducks in that
flock and they flew off before I even
got half as close as I needed to be but
I'm sure they're not the only duck on
this
Lake now Ducks actually have a language
of sorts there's a hey baby I'm here
call there's that num nom this is tasty
call there's the basic
quack well that duck came right into the
call and I was able to close the
distance with him pretty good when I got
closer I could tell he wasn't a malard
he's some sort of diving duck and those
usually don't taste as good as malards
so I'm just going to kind of let that
one
[Music]
go I'm just working my way up and down
this River and around the lake just
looking for slews and Marshy
spots
Oh my
legs I spent about 3 hours paddling
around looking for ducks didn't shoot
any and oh I am tired and hungry I think
I am ready for
breakfast
little something to keep me warm while I
[Music]
cook got little butter and honey in this
jar we're going to let that warm
up pour some honey butter on that some
fresh pan fried bread with honey butter
and pork gel bacon
M few things in the world taste better
than fresh homemade breads smothered in
melted butter and honey
I'll tell you what the rain has eased up
a little bit I want to take advantage of
that I want to go get some firewood and
bring it into the shelter so it can dry
off a little bit and maybe just maybe I
can build a fire tonight if nothing else
cutting firewood will keep me
warm
look at there's water all the way
through that
log there we go got a nice pile of wet
wood it's mostly dry on the inside but
it's so wet on the outside it's going to
take take a lot of heat to get it dry so
it can ignite in order to get the fire
started I'm going to need dry kindling
and lots of it and the problem is is
where do you find it all the branches
and Moss and grass here are just soaking
wet I got these two dry pieces of wood I
found in the shelter so I need to chop
them down and make them into kindling
and keep that kindling bone
dry each dry piece of wood I'm going to
lay over here where it's nice and
dry
another great fire starter is charcoal
but this stuff's soaking wet so we're
going to dry it
out there you go that works real good
also use your stove to dry out other
pieces of wood
I'm out of water luckily around here
there is no short supply of
water if the water you're filtering out
has a lot of sediment it'll gum up your
filter really quick so I use the
carrying case for my water filter to
kind of do an initial
screening the carrying case will f
filter out all the sand and sticks and
other
things I just hang up the dirty water
and gravity pulls it through a filter
down the hose and fills up my water
bottle all right let's go and pinch it
off rumor has it there's brook trout in
this Lake and uh I haven't caught in a
brook trout in a long long time I got my
rod rigged up with a little fly it's got
a black leech with a gold bead on it I
don't know a ton about this Lake but
most lakes like this in Alaska have
leeches in it and trout love to eat
leeches I think I want to bring a hot
water bottle with me fishing but I don't
want to sit and wait for a pot to boil
on my
stove woo yeah that's
toasty oh that feels SMS
nice well the fishing isn't going great
the rain's picking up and I am soaked to
the bone I think I might head
back
I am soaking wet and very cold my hot
water bottle is lost its oomph I think I
need to do something to warm myself up
and I got an
idea all right let's get warm I'm
starting to regret my
idea
okay half of me is being boiled alive
half of me is freezing to death and
there's just a little bit of sweet
spot okay oh I think I've got the
temperature dialed in pretty good that
hot water pipe is Just a Touch Too Hot
so I got a little bit of that warm
waterfall coming in mixing with it just
just perfect between the hiking and the
canoeing I'm a little bit sore this is
nice
oh well I missed lunch and I'm a bit
hungry so uh I think I'm going to have a
hot spring
snack
so
good oh this is nice but I'm starting to
get
overheated a little laded getting out of
that hot
[Applause]
water I don't have any towels so I'm
just going to have to put all my clothes
wet and dry out
slowly honestly I don't feel any wetter
than I did before I got into the hot
springs but man I'm a whole lot warmer
I'm starting to get hungry so I am going
to make a tinf foil
dinner little salt pepper Little Pork
gel bacon on
there green onion and a whole bunch of
cilantro
if you're doing this at home use Italian
sausage or keilbasa instead of brw wor
and it's even better but hey you know
use what you
got all righty oh I think the rain eased
up I'm going to make a fire I better do
it
now there we
go
even with a dry kindling that fire isn't
taking aggressively there's so much
humidity in the
air I put these wet pieces of wood up
here so they can dry but they'll also
act as a roof if it starts to rain which
will protect the
fire
I can hear it sizzling in there oh nice
working the fire is drying my pants out
look at
that
there we go I forgot to bring a fork so
I made some Chopsticks that is smelling
like it's
ready
there m that smells
good oh the sweet potato so
good
oh that was
good the meat and the sweet potato a
little bit of salt man that's good stuff
I uh I think it's time to roast a
marshmallow oh that's
good got some uh lemon pound cake here
cup of hot chocolate with some cake for
dessert not too shabby at all
I got to tell you what I'm feeling very
fortunate right now got a nice warm fire
the rain has been really light I got a
full belly I think there's a really good
chance I'm going to go to bed dry and
warm really the only thing I can
complain about right now is that I've
got two
visitors get out of
my don't get get out of there get out of
there here come on come
on yeah
okay come on this way this way buddy
come on come
on there's mice all over oh mice can
cause a lot of damage anything fuzzy
they want to steal it and take it to
their nest so they'll chew holes in your
sleeping bag they'll pull your hair out
they'll chew up your jackets and of
course they can get into your food and
ruin your
food
dude that's that's a different
one he's a little fatter than the other
one we're just going to try to clean up
really well and get all my stuff off the
ground so they don't chew it
up sure a mouse can still get to it if
they want to but at least I'm not making
it
easy hopefully that'll keep my stuff
away from the
mice oh these socks are so
wet it it feels so good to be warm and
dry but it's late I've got to turn off
the camera and I'll see you in the
morning oh good morning I had this
nightmare that I was rabbit hunting and
I shot a rabbit and when I got close and
picked it up it was someone's Pomeranian
tell this old lady that I shot her dog
and thought I was a
rabbit oh everything is so damp you hang
up your clothes and they do not dry at
all I've got an entire chain of dry
clean clothes but I'm saving it for the
airplane ride home don't want to get the
airplane all
gross oh it's raining good outside it's
going to be wet
today oh this plate is disgustingly
dirty
H well they're not exactly dry but
they're world's better than
yesterday I'll tell you what this has
been a pretty cool little Adventure but
I am ready to get out of the rain think
it's time to head back back to the beach
I got a plane to catch oh I'm going to
get
soaked
oh there's a seal right
there well I got a bit of bad news I
just got a message from the pilot that
they're weathered in at catch can and
they can't come get me I don't know how
bad the weather is I don't know how long
it's going to last all I know is the
pilot said he'd give me an update in 2
hours that's how it is here in Alaska
you have to bow to the weather the
weather doesn't bow to
you I need to get out of this rain I'm
getting
soaked
oh it's good to get out of the rain I'm
wet from the waist down and a little bit
cold but at least I'm not in the rain
anymore I get cold just sitting here but
if I go out and walk around I get more
wet so I've got to do little exercises
under the tarp try to stay
warm I don't have any more cooking Fuel
and I don't have a ton of food left so
just having a really simple
lunch well the rain eased up and I got a
message from the pilot they're still
socked in and Katch Ken so I'm not
getting rescued anytime soon maybe in a
couple hours something will change or
maybe I'll be stuck here for a day or
two I'm using the break in the weather
to walk around I'm freezing I'm just
going to walk up and down this beach
till I'm
warm barely got half a dozen laps done
and it's starting to rain a little a
little
[Music]
bit well it's been 5 hours and I just
got a message from the pilot that
they're going to try to leave we'll see
if they can make it
I can hear a plane there's the
[Music]
plane thank you so much oh
I've got to catch my flight to Anchorage
so they just dropped me off on a dock
right here outside the
[Music]
airport oh
heat got some dry clothes
on
give
me Miss I missed you and Jacob yes I
kind of wanted oh guys it's good to be
back home and with the family hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video if you want
to see more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel make sure to click
subscribe all right I'll see you next
video everyone if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel we have hundreds of
videos just like this and don't forget
to click subscribe so you can see other
great videos every Saturday morning and
hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for
watching